بمناسبه الحديث عن كاس العالم فمع نهايه
الان كمان من الصاج التواصل جلسه بتعمل
ملخصات للي صار عليها من نقاشات حلو وفي
مقدمتهم طبعا تويتر تويتر نشر احصائيات عن
كاس العالم وكشف انه خلال فتره البطوله في
147 مليار امبرشن او انطباع تم تسجيلهم
هذا الرقم تخطى بمراحل الانتباهات خلال
الكاس العالم
2018 وحتى يعتبر ضعف انتباعات اولمبياد
طوكيو اما بالنسبه لاكثر اللحظات اللي جمع
التفاعل خلال كاس العالم وهذه تم قياسات
عدد التغريدات عن الموضوع في الدقيقه
الواحده في المرتبه الخامسه كان في هدف
نيمار في الدقيقه 106 في مباراه ربع
النهائي مع كرواتيا في المرتبه الرابعه
عندنا هدف دي ماريا اللي كان الثاني
للارجنتين في النهائي والمرتبه الثالثه
برده في الربع النهائي بين كرواتيا
والبرازيل واللحظه كانت لحظه تضييع
البرازيل لاخر ضربه وفوز كرواتيا اما في
المرتبه الثانيه فكان هدف فرنسا الثاني
بقدم مبابي والتعادل في النهائي وطبعا
المرتبه الاولى وكما هو متوقع لحظه نهايه
ضربات الجزاء في النهائي افوز الارجنتين
اكثر اللاعبين اللي تم الحديث عنهم خلال
كاس العالم هما الكوري صنهي من ورونالدو
ونيمار ومبابي وميسي اما المنتخب اكثر من
سنه فكان الاول الارجنتين بعدين البرازيل
وفرنسا والبرتغال وكرواتيا وعلى غير تويتر
كمان على فكره حتى جوجل اعلنت تعبر تغريده
لرئيسها ان المحرك او انه البحث على
المحرك سجل اعلى مستوياته في 25 سنه خلال
النهائي وكانه كل العالم في تلك اللحظه
كان بيبحث عن نفس الشيء بحسب كلام